Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to The End of Disney.
Now, I don't mean the literal end of Disney. That would be kind of sad.
But we don't need to worry about that because we're playin' (breath)
Five Nights at Treasure Island.
Now, if you guys remember way back when Five Nights at Freddy's was first released,
There was a game called Five Nights at Treasure Island.
It was one of the first Five Nights at Freddy's fan games that I ever played, if not, the first.
And, I saw this game on GameJolt and I kind of have a policy against FNAF fan games
But the developer said that this was his "last attempt at making a Five Nights at Treasure Island game"
and he wanted to finish it off strong.
So, I thought it'd be kinda cool to play this game to see how far along, number one, the developer has come,
and to kinda reminisce about the time after FNAF and how that kinda changed a whole bunch of shit.
(reading the dialog in game)
So to win, I have to do something BEFORE the time runs out. Is that what I'm told here?
And then people are gonna come by and I'm 'onna stab 'em with a cattle prod.
Oh...
Oooohhhhh
I do remember this!
I totally remember this!
Oh, wow-
Hi, Melty Face Mickey!
Eugh
Hey there....
Hai, buddy.
Oh, I remember!
Oh, I definitely- oulgh
What are you?
(gasp) Is that a rabbit?
OH, that's a rabbit!
I forget the name of...
...the rabbit...
Oh, HAI.
Is that Foxy?
Just plain ol' Foxy?
Or is that Goofy?
Oh man, I actually legitimately remember this.
Seems to have seen better days than this. But it's kinda interesting to see how far it's come
because that's almost been, if not, exactly 2 years from now, which is kind of incredible.
And I don't know why I'm getting errors on mah buttons.
Not able to do anything here.
Maybe I'm just not supposed to be able to do anything at all.
In fact, I don't even know why I came here.
Press and hold to charge the generator?
Am I doing it?
I think I am.
So do I just gotta-
Do I just hold this?
I'm gonna die, aren't I?
I'm gonna die in a lotta weird ways.
I'm goin' be killed-
I'm goin' get killed.
fff-
AHYE
I DID IT.
YAY
I THINK I DID IT.
I DUNNO.
What did that do?
OOOooohhhhhhh
The generators are for each individual camera!
Oh geez...
Why can't I hear anything?
I thought this was loud but-
There it is.
What is that?
Ho-kay.
Alright, I can hear that now.
That's for damn definitely sure.
So I gotta charge ALL the generators
That's what I'm supposed to be able to g-AHha
You wanna see my head come off?
AYYE-FAHCK YOU, BUDDY. (ง⩾ᗝ⩽)ง
That's MY HEAD! ᕙ(⪰ᗝ⪯)ᕗ
Alrighty then.
OH, is that supposed to be me?
Have I been RIPPED from my skin?
Oh boy.
Oh buddy boo.
Well, alright. Now I know what I need to do.
Egh.
Ah, God, why that face?
Eugh.
So, yeah. This is kinda interesting to see how far along it's come.
And still be able to get scared by it.
Because, I think, for some reason, this one really resonated with people.
One, because it's Disney characters, and obviously...
Yeah, all that jazz.
But- Two, it's just kind of a silly concept.
I-I-In all reality, the juxtaposition of Disney's normally superbly happy, lovely, lovely, lovely time.
I wonder what would happen if I just get everything close to being done
and theeeeeennnnn
swap 'em all out.
So, if I could just do that...
I mean, this is gonna be pretty difficult to do.
And now I definitely hear that music.
I dunno if I broke something before and wasn't able to hear it.
But now I definitely do.
What's that?
Did I hear somethin'?
Nope, okay.
Still 12 AM. (actually just turned 1)
If I could just get through the FIRST NIGHT, I'm gonna consider this a victory.
But I don't even know if I'm 'oin' be able to do dat...
I hear that!
I friggin' hear som'in'!
Unless that's just the music, because if it is,
Good God.
I-
I HEARD THAT.
HAI.
I heard a deep
RUMBLY IN MY TUMBLY.
Okay, I'm gonna go then.
I'm gonna assume that everything is-
I HEARD THAT AS WELL.
I keep hearing deep rumbly bumblies.
I'm assuming that the rumbly bumblies is badly wadly.
I'm goin' diely wiely.
AH-FAUCK YOU.
NO NO YA-A-
F-FACK YOU. (งòᗝó)ง
I'm zip-zappin'.
I'm zappy-wapping.
Nobody's gonna get me when I'm zap-tastic.
Close there.
Oh, hey.
You're getting awfully close to me, aren't ya?
Aren't ya, ya jibbly joo?
Don't move.
Just don't move.
Don' fuckin' move.
Imma come back to ya.
Soon as I ZAP ya.
AHH-I ZAP 'em.
ZAP 'EM.
ZAPPY WAP 'EM?
Am I zip zappin'?
Chargin', chargin', chargin'.
CHARGIN', CHARGIN', chargin'.
IIIIIIIII'VE
DONE IT-
Oh shit.
CHARGE 'EM.
ZIPZAPZAP
ZAPPIDY WAPPY.
ZAPPY WAPYYYYYYY
Anybody wanna give me a zip zap zappity wap?
Aw, don't tell me I've got-
Oh fuck.
Don't tell me I gotta actually survive?
Oh fuck-aye
Ah, fuck.
FUCK-A-DUCK.
But not
DAWNALD.
Alright.
Fucking-
Goddammit
It's just the generators, isn't it?
FAHCK.
There's nothing left to CHEARGE.
I just gotta survive and
MASH
my ZAPPY buttons.
Maybe I'm just addicted to it and I like the
FEEL
of being electrocuted.
Hi-
Oh-C-can I- Can I
zap 'em?
Okay, alright theeeeeeennn-
N-N-N
I didn't see you last time, so I'm assuming that happened before and I didn't see it.
Maybe I shouldn't just be WAILING on mah buttons like this.
Gotta have some self control when it comes to button mashin'.
I just can't wait until I hear Goofy's
AHHHHH-hoo
Uh
Hoo-hoo
HOO-WEE
I mean, is-admittedly, it is only night one.
So, admittedly, I should be able to do this without too much
truahble.
Don't do that.
I don't know where you is, but don't
KILL MEEEE
ZIP ZAP ZAPPITY WAP!
I think I'm okay.
Maybe.
I dunno.
I didn't see him appear...
But I see a distinct Mickey ear pattern in that.
YAEAAAAEAY.
I DID IT.
HURRAY.
I'M THE WINNER.
I'VE DONE SOMETHING WITH MY LIFE.
I'VE ACCOMPLISHED A LOT.
WHAT- THAT WAS IiIT?
That was IT?
Aw, c'mon, maaan.
Oh, nooo...
OOH
WAIT, NO
I CAN DO.
NIGHT TWO.
That's right, you just continue. (great rhymes, Markimoo. 10/10)
Er, I thought you would've rolled into it.
Okay.
(reading dialog on screen)
Well, this seems, like,
WAAAY more complicated than last night.
Why do you gotta be such a
DOUUUUuuUUOOOiiCHE
Alrighty then
Here we go.
I guess.
Somethin' about bad stuff happenin'.
I don't know where Donald's head is gonna come into play here
but m-m-probably goin'-not goin' be gOOOD.
I gotta admit, the-the ambiance music-
Woah.
No? Okay.
The ambiance music?
I like that.
It's very good.
Very good.
VERY good.
Good thing I'm two days from retirement.
ALSO
Again, I wanna PONDER
WHHHHHHYYYYYYYY
Am I back here?
WHHYY did I come into an abandoned place
where everything is death and destruction
and Goofy wants to "goof" me
in the "goof hole"...
and everything's gonna be bad?
Then Donald wants to-
NoOOOOO.
Donald wants me to literally fuck-a-duck.
NOOOOOOOO.
What was that?
Was there anything?
Am I a big bubble lowin' baby?
A bubba lowin'?
A bubba
bubba
bubba blowin'.
I didn't do anything-
What the fuck was that?
What're you sayin' to me?
Is that Goofy?
Was that Donald?
Was that Oswald?
I got
THREEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
'Scuse me?
Pardon me?
What'd you say?
I dunnooOOOOOOOOOOO
I dunnoo-ooo-ooooo
No
No you don't
No you do nooOOOOOoooT
Hey, Oswald!
How ya doin'?
Oh, you're near
byyyyyyyyyyyyyyyy
Can't believe I forgot your name
Very sorry about that, Oswald.
If you could stop staring at me while I'm charging this,
THAT WOULD BE GREATLY APPRECIATED.
OH, YOU'RE JUST GONNA KEEP LOOKIN' AT ME THEN, HUH?
IS IT BECAUSE I'M-
OH, FUCKING FUCK.
Only
DICKS?
OH
GOD
NOOOOOO
Okay...
I think- I think it's good.
I'm gonna get all the generators
nnnnnnnnnnnnn-NOW.
Zip zap zooobity bap.
I think I'm good.
Unless there's some secrets happening over here.
Oswald's back.
Ooh, who's head is
thatuauaaat?
Oh, the head's gone huh?
Oh no, wait, the head just moved.
OOOHH, that's
MICKEY!
Oh, GOOOOOOOOD.
I was looking for a
frieand.
Oh
No heavens, no hells, just this.
Wah-zasa nazasa zaza aza...
AUYE AUYE AUYE AUYE
KAAAAAaaaAAUUUIIAAAAYY
WhyYY YOU DO THAT?
WHAT'S THAT?
I SAW THAT!
I SAW THAT OVER THERE!
YOU CAN'T HIDE BEHIND TIM!
I saw you...
In the darkness...
Man, good ol' Goof-boy is still hiding away, there.
I dunno if anything's gonna happen when Goof-boy comes out.
Maybe
DEATH.
Maybe escort to the heaven and the hell.
If I have a moment to actually talk and not panic,
I wanna say that this game is actually made way better than the original.
I would have to say-
"Who disturbs the dead?"
Uh
ME?
My name is Markiplier.
Uh
Professional Dead Disturber?
Oh, hey, nice giggles there.
YAAAAAAAAA-
HOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
I made it through another one.
That one went with less incident but I have a funny feeling that night 3 is gonna be a
sonovabitch.
Night 3.
What'd ya got for me?
The first two were easy.
I only died once and that's when I didn't know what I was doing.
So what have you got for me?
(reading dialog on screen)
Well, I dunno who to believe.
The guy that told me there are three
Or the guy that told me there were only two.
OH WAIT, it's the same person.
(deep breath in)
YOOOUUU.
How do I go to the third floor?
That is an excellent question.
And why is there a meat freezer
in
Treasure Island?
All excellent questions.
O-kay.
Sorry.
Sorry-
Hai, okay.
Good, okay.
He went away
Whoever that was.
Don't know who that was.
Might've been Oswald.
Or Ortensia.
By the way, I wanna mention, I like this mechanic.
I like the mechanic of having to do something at every camera.
It keeps me moving around which is kinda nice.
Something that I haven't seen
in a lot of FNAF fan games.
Or the main games themselves.
I-It's a- It's a symbol activity and it's not a lot.
It's akin to the music box from Five Nights at Freddy's
two-OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO.
I'M 'ONNA DIE.
BUuut, it allows me to-
What did I DO!?
"SHOW MY FACE AFTER WHAT I'VE DONE"?
WHAT DID I DO?
I WAS JUST MEEEEEEEE.
I BARELY EVEN FINISHED THE FIRST GAME.
I THINK IT WAS A DEMO WHEN I PLAYED IT.
Well, that's not good.
HELLOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO.
HAI!
Hello everybody!
M-Ah, fuck.
The-the
TOOBZZ?
The TOOBZ?
Are you talkin' about the YouToobz?
Oh, boy.
Oswald's up next.
Oh , boy. Oswald's here.
JESUS
JIMINY
CHRISTMAS
THEY ARE QUICK TODAY.
OH boy.
Oh, is he here?
Is he or (grumbly sounds or something)
AAAEEEHHHHHH.
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAND
HAH-BOOSKI.
Okay.
How do I get-
-to the meat freezer?
Oh, that's not a good sound.
I like that sound absolutely the opposite of good.
(English, please, Mark.)
I mean, a lot.
I mean,
I don't like it.
I hate it.
I mean,
it's the worst.
it's kinda cool, I guess.
What the fuck is happening?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO HIDE UNDER MAH DEEEESK.
Oh fuck, I'm 'onna die, aren't I?
Hai!
How do I go to the meat freezer?
Oh-AHHH!
FUCKING
GOOFYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYY
I GOT GOOFED.
I GOT GOOFED ALL OVER.
I GOT GOOF JUICE ALL OVER ME.
Alright, so anyway,
That's all I'm gonna play for this game.
I don't think I'm gonna do a full play through of this.
But, it's really well made.
I mean, Five Nights at Freddy's fan games, they've been making them for about 2 years now, so it's hard to get some innovation out of it.
But I like it.
I like the concept. It's got some heart and soul to it.
It's got some depth to the story, it's got -- reminiscent of the old one, which is kinda nice
to have the connective tissue be there.
But, alas,
I don't think I'm gonna play a full version of this  game but I do applaud the works of
the developer, Photo Negative Mickey, and the Theteod Dev Team.
So,
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed this. Let me know what you thought of it down in the, uh, comments below.
And if you wanna see the original that I played, I'll put that in the description as well.
Features a little ol' young me about 2 years ago that
it dat- it dat me- it dat BOIIIIII.
Dat boi.
Dat me.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
And, as always, I will see you
in the next video.
Buh-bye!